[Music]
Congrats on being part of the Toronto
Film Festival that's an amazing
achievement I just want to say congrats
that's it we're done that's it but
listen the fact is that everyone
watching this interview know 99.9% of
the people watching this will have not
seen the movie yet and so I hate asking
that generic thing but could you sort of
talk about what the film was about and
let's start with that she's a writer
it's all centered around one man who is
who's that and kind of her journey
moving out from believing everything
blindly to discovering what the truth is
and that she's kind of maybe has more
power than she thinks I'll ask you how
did this thing land on your desk how did
you get you know involved with us it
happened like actually two years ago at
Cannes Film Festival 5:00 a.m. in the
morning at the bar I was completely
smashed and someone introduced me a
producer and they say that's the
producer of whiplash David Lancaster and
then he asked me do you know any good
cinematographer and I said yes and I
gave him name of my cinematographer and
then he watched my work because we did
together with my stalker and then he
offered me a script then it means these
things happens at the festival at the
bar I was gonna say to you see you're
you're basically saying that all the
times I've gone out drinking at a film
festival can all pay off which is a very
unusual way sure um before we get into
actually I'm gonna involve you two right
now talk a little bit about how you both
got involved was it one of these things
where you get sent a script or did they
send you like an idea how did you tool
and with this I'm well I was in New York
for some reason oh I was doing something
else in New York and I met with David
Lancaster the producer and he told me
about I don't know
you were due to that point but malgo and
was doing it and obviously catherine he
was tell him about the writer and yeah
they both sounded really passionate
about this about this thing and I had
read a synopsis of the script I hadn't
touched you read the script yet and it
it sounded amazing but it didn't quite
do it justice like when I actually read
the script it was it was amazing but
still from the snots I mean had a drunks
do it and yeah that's how I got involved
I said yes I want to do it after I read
the script and then it's all just went
from that I read the script and I was
dying to work with these people with
Marga I'd seen her movies I loved them
and so I wanted to be part of this when
did you what is it like because you have
to play someone who you know like that
culty kind of you know what I mean like
where you so charismatic is that a real
challenge for you like to turn that you
know what I mean to turn it on to turn
it on yeah oh my god I don't know I got
I got a lot of help you know doing that
from-from Mago hypercars Monty were
joking them actually you know in the
story I play the shepherd but really
Mago is our Shepherd did you pay him $5
or $10 to say that five nothing but no
but this was really a passion project
for all of us and we we believed in this
story and and and I'm really proud about
how it turned out well one of the things
that I found talking to different
directors writers and actors is that
everyone has a different process with
the way they'd like to work some
directors love to shoot the rehearsal
and some directors want to like rehearse
a ton and then start shooting other
actors love music or they want to be
silent before they're shooting talk a
little bit about the way each of you
likes to work on set and what it was
like working together on this
you know to me I'm like very I'm kind of
experience because I've done before it's
my first feature English debuted but
before I've done like seven feature
films in Europe boring arthouse you know
for festivals and I was like I said no I
had to change something then I'm kind of
experienced then I'm doing always short
cuts you know I'm not doing a lot of
rehearsals I'm trying to cast the people
which I I know what I can expect and
etcetera how to use them and all of
these elements that I have my DP always
we are doing together then it's really
like I don't have to talk to a lot or I
don't have to do a lot of rehearsals
then I'm actually really doing
everything like in my head kind of very
short cuts yeah but but mugga you also
really you're so visual so we talk like
when we were preparing I think we talked
a lot about everything and you had a lot
of ideas but but we never ended up
shooting anything that made it to the
movie the way that that you had
explained it to me before it was always
on the day you know Margo would be
looking at the shot and and it would
sort of magic magic would happen
situation I have to see what I'm doing
in the monitor not like with my I know
through the monitor for the camera I and
then I know you know they would like to
change and if it doesn't and if it
doesn't work what would you say
I'm sure I'm saying that I don't like it
I don't like it because you know
probably they work I mean he works in US
and I did you actually say after a take
I don't like it it's very bad yes really
yes that is understand that that's why
married us it's not possible right it
never happened because have you in your
lives have you ever been told after we
know it's very no no I know I genuinely
think it's the best way though cuz you
know you're right yeah you know that she
actually does like it and you would do
something you had you thought it's kind
of good I mean I'll go ii don't like it
did you find that actually cuz i could
see a lot of actors are looking for that
that reinforcement that what they're
doing i'm not saying a blanket statement
but i look a lot of people they want to
hear they're doing something good so did
you find that it almost made you work
harder to get her to say that was good I
mean that's not maybe a bad question but
like it it kept me on my toes right but
who so sometimes it was really hard to
know what was good and what not and so
in in beginning it was very almost
shocking but after a few days I started
to really sort of ease into it and and
and and feel very confident that she
knows what she's doing
so their entire takes where it's just
now go in the background just blood I
mean you sound you know it's a problem
with the sound of the movie because I'm
talking all the time during the thing I
so bad I can't stand there's more blood
I really I hope at some point down the
road when the film is on like blu-ray or
whatever there can be some sort of
sizzle reel yes you after takes with
your commentary like that was [ __ ] or
that was more blood or a documentary
about me because it's gonna be very
funny
sure may be more successful in my movies
because I've done a lot of interviews
and I've never heard this kind of stuff
which is amazing for each of you Eastern
Europe right exactly I need to go to
Poland for more yeah more shoots for
each of you so I'm curious you're
writing the script what was often times
when you're writing there's like a huge
hurdle you need to overcome
in terms of like maybe there's a story
point that you're not able to crack or
whatever so I'll start with you what was
the the big challenge writing the script
that you overcame said so his other line
was based on a short story I wrote years
before and I adapted and then I think
honestly the biggest hurdle it sounds
odd but I got myself into a really odd
headspace I watched about 10
documentaries and Colts back-to-back I
was writing very late at night I think
the biggest hurdle honestly was I kind
of came out of it and was kind of had to
like put it aside and let it sit because
it is just like it's quite a poisonous
script is the wrong term but it's not a
light script and so genuinely like
they're you know writing is a job you
sit in front of the computer and you sit
down and you do your work but it did
genuinely feel like a catharsis to ride
it and and it meant that once I'd
written it like I wrote it very quickly
I kind of felt like I'd gotten something
out but also that I kind of had to treat
myself with care because I'm it's you
know dealing with things about like
abuse and cults and cults of personality
and like it's not light and it's
something that I think it's quite
important for creatives across all
levels of making things is that you have
to be careful about what you're filming
and doing and kind of be kind of give
yourself time to process feelings and
and and kind of darkness if you're doing
dark pieces I think yeah I'm curious for
you obviously no matter what you're
making you never have enough time you
never have enough money what was the
thing while filming that you were like
how the f are we gonna do this
with what you have the time I mean 25
shooting days it was like incredible
right and even to Eastern European
director it's not a lot I mean then it
was very difficult and to to film each
scene in 25 days yeah time I have to I
must say time I I would love to have
like more shooting days because it was
really a challenge so what I really love
I love to to have a distance I love to
shoot a movie and then to have a break
to the editing and do like one or two
three days kind of reshoot that's the
method I'm usually working then III
couldn't on that project then but
is good because I have to like put
myself together I actually I actually
have spoken to a lot of directors and
like in Asia a lot of times they'll
shoot movies and then they'll take a
break for like a week or two and then
come back to I'm doing we are doing like
this also like me and even probably
Koski our Oscar winner he's also doing
always like this I think it's a kind of
method then this time I couldn't use
that method then I was completely awake
all the time I was like totally like
this very stiff because I knew I have to
use my time and it's a only one chance
then it's very different that also I had
like American producers even I love them
but you know behind me and very new very
new situation sure more more I think
more money more problems yeah but this
dream is like not a lot of money it's
very little money I can tell you of
course maybe is that yeah compared to my
polish teams is more but it still otter
to dolar diva I mean a Devo hold that
thought I want to ask you guys something
real quick yeah because there were no
challenges for us right now I am
actually curious though you're reading
the script you're getting ready to film
what's the thing that you're reading in
the script that you're most excited to
do and what's the thing that you're like
that's gonna be a really tough shooting
day if anything you go first
I don't know I didn't really I expected
that it would because obviously it was a
dark one that it would be a difficult
shoot but in a way for a lot of people
you would have thought the weather was
kind of difficult but actually it worked
because it was supposed to be like a
tough journey so it works so I don't
know specifically yeah oh god it was
really tough the water oh my god there's
it yeah there's a scene where were in
the water and
zero degrees yeah and we had to get
fully in the story I I baptized a
Rafie's character and and you know Margo
I think you were wearing like these like
these really long what do they call
theirs waiters like and so she's
standing right behind us and and and you
know giving us notes while the cameras
rolling of course they should all be on
the making of and and and so I think i
dunk you and then malgo of course while
we're still rolling I don't know if we
can do it again comment re-offense and
sure completely I listen every million
other questions but I'm just gonna have
to stop there and I'm just gonna say
congrats on the movie Congrats on being
part of the Toronto International Film
Festival and before we wrap I have to
give a huge thank you
the only reason we get to be here is
because of great sponsors it's expensive
to cover this fest a huge thank you to
Nordstrom Canada for being a great
sponsor to us and seriously I hope
everyone sees the movie thank you so
much for stopping by thank you thank you